belletti di ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati
supporto al con pietro che abbiamo
finito le 22 state stage si chiama così
approfitti due stage adesso dobbiamo
fare il terzo che credo che sia una roba
molto più incasinata del solito ci siamo
ok cosa cosa cosa vedo
ma che [ __ ] amico a gardaland che figata
incredibile aver finalmente credo che
siamo arrivati ad una parte un po
incastrata selezionare il percorso dopo
di che procedeva sulla stanza di
disassemblaggio va bene non ho idea di
cosa sia la parola ora sicuramente tutti
voi sapete che tra di noi come gruppo ci
è finita welcome to the fields bisogna
fare qua
questi allora questi io presumo che male
ci sono il torrente che tu sei quello
protetto ovviamente devi darmi il q il
cubo che potete volatile il qb ok ok è
veramente il cubo cioè di tulli e punta
lo sento e spacca le ammazzo sia mazza
lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo che tanto
fece così lo sapevo io sapevo sapevo io
dio maria n ok ce l'ho fatta si è fatta
ok giocate aveva fatto ancora niente
dirige il razzo verso di me io li dirigo
verso come torretta passa grande ok
grande allora adesso fai così spa treni
non altro sito di politico
di sicuro allora facciamo così ok
perfetto
ok ma io devo distrutti
ora dovresti andare preci pro una volta
che sei lì ma ok un nota gli steli sei a
posto ma il papà la mamma o le diciamo
divisi ma siamo più insieme con di credo
di no per adesso meglio così come non mi
devi fare dal fastidio e adesso è vabbè
io posso andare qua
anch'io esatto
poi il pulsante la cosa fa il pulsante
cade una sfera che casino esto livello
porca eva metti un portale li l'altro
metti ho detto mai soli basta così
prende al volo perfetto amico è caduta
proprio fuori fantastico
la madonna lebron james lebron james che
faccio non so che cosa disagio vedendo
laggiù guarda quindi vai e ma se la
porto dentro figlio non lo so fammi
pensare ah ho capito ho capito subito
dai rifacciamo rifacciamo riferiti da
quando non sono prima che io ti dico io
ti dico vai lajatico baila ok di
comandare ok by quando no no no no no no
no no non aspetta ok si nome giusto
bye bye la bella veloce veloce loach e
veloce però trovo perfetto bravissimo ma
sei proprio bello forlì è giusto grazie
amico bravo che sarà difficile è
smarcata giusta che sarà solo uno fai te
ma tu da rifiuta esponenziale 15 poi
veramente un casino on the work a vacca
che brutto gioco mi sono pagato
fortissimo a chi guarda lo sai cos'è
questo guarda a zachary booth
[Musica]
dall'altra parte c'è un cubo di sotto
mamma mia che c'è un cubo di sott'occhio
cosa che casi aiuto qua c'è un che per
facilitare o arrivato il cubo aspetta
addirittura un altra roba c'è un portale
più incasinato ancora ok bene ho capito
sei così o ok ok ok ed io adesso mi ai
miei smaterializzato il muro così io
posso prendere la barriera andare a fare
i money graber ok va bene che fa quello
che scusami eh non lo so adesso
scopriamo sai così con un muovere niente
perché sono casino ti diverti ma sa se
non sto vedendo un attimo amico mio so
come si fa e non ho guardato
assolutamente le soluzioni
giuro
e stato metta a guardare soluzioni di
due spagnoli
c'è comunque un casi nato pur sapendo
cosa devo fare fait è ok vieni corri
corri corri di qua qua ricordi vieni
corri corri corri corri veloci non solo
se lasciarla più veloce ciao pietro a
toglierla carnico prima le cose partivo
anch'io prima cioè che ci sia arrivato
io dopo don far così c'è quanto è malata
di mente st parte come una persona
normale potrebbe mai arrivarci possibile
è difficilissimo prende troppo mentre
c'è una roba veramente ad atroci e
madonna 6 non mi chiedere cosa dobbiamo
fare però credo sia una piscina però non
fare il bagno hard vieni facciamo le
cose
vado prima io che ha vinto sì vabbè ma
non ce la faremo mai mai troppo di noi
siamo solo due youtuber non potremmo
fare mai nulla di tutto ciò a free muse
con aspetta la voce ancora qua c'è
qualcosa e non ci stanno a vedere quindi
c'è qua aspetta vieni prevedere per
sempre entrambi
qua c'è una esp e vieni vieni qua arrivo
far fare al solo giochi corpo allora ok
ok allora ci dobbiamo sparare laggiù
questo sicuro ora metti no c'è un
portale guarda l'aspetto metti aiuto
amico non sono capace a c'è un buco qua
c'è una roba qua vieni vieni mi ricordo
sono io allora io faccio questo emette i
portali l'assoluto adesso fammi portale
da te fa mi fa notare per venire da te
fa meno 14
sua madre morta un trapanato ok e i
portali ci sono ora tu devi entrare
dentro qui qualche modo devi sparare
ma passiamo trapanare adesso in questo
momento entra senso che non a porta che
già difficile concentrarsi allora io
devo farlo da solo o meglio allora io ti
faccio i portali perfetta light on a
yahoo
no aspetta amico aspetta sbagliato da
lei se incasinando più le cose di
controllo sia già ok a lui su redditi e
blu di san franco di differente quindi
qua ora ok ok ometto questo qua riesci a
lanciarti lavora crunch armi perfetta ma
il lancio di lanciati pietro come eccolo
bravo perfetto perfetto
ok adesso cosa si fa ball aver soffocato
il robot gli atp sul muro la tv qua ok
ok adesso tutorial nella stanza di prima
forse da qua io riesco a prendere ma da
noi tuoi bordello e lo rischio non
riuscivo a fare neanche le espressioni
matematiche cosa voglio farvi fare
supporta ora dovresti no
lo vedi tu perché sei stupido come
persona
dov'è il buco che è sopra di terzo la
battua testa ecco li faccio un portale
adesso che hai fatto questo perfetto
ok non così sei stupido rifai rifai la
stessa cosa filati rime ok solo il cubo
di lasciare che aspetta aspetta aspetta
di ballo ballo bye bye bye bye ha preso
già fatto senza farlo basta siamo folli
ma abbiamo una laurea ad honorem una
laurea ad honorem vieni qua amico non
sai neanche venire qua non sa neanche
nell'altra parte iv corda vabbè ma
questo gioco è un malato che si sono
troppo difficili raga questi livelli
sono troppo difficile allora io vedrei
il prossimo come
se vediamo che la pasta e è difficile
allora lasciamo perdere
no raga ma è la malattia
shampoo ragazzi credo che possiamo
concludere cosa no vabbè fa vedere solo
cose solo per curiosità questo questo
qua ti fa saltare più in alto quanto mi
ricordo credo a quello che mi faccio
tardi in alto vediamo sì ecco che ti fa
saltare a ok può sempre andare pure muro
si ok mai esattamente quello che non
volevo vedere acea la barriera che pirla
prova prova adesso o mio dio no dai
e non so se rimbalzi sua barriera
infatti sporca ma voglio mai date un hub
e devi sporcarla tu perché se forse
possibile portare di mimì era vice
qualche la tua prova non so se si sporca
ci si sporca barriera ma tolti border ma
dopo ci sono amico ce l'ho fatto vieni
canta tentazione di toglierti la porta
il portale ma non lo faccio perché siamo
arrivati troppo avanti finora vabbè dai
poiché via iembo arrivato ce l'ha fatta
dai sì vieni vieni quindi no non è vero
non era scherzavo ma per un attimo ciò
che aiuta anche io però una parte
l'abbiamo fatta da il caso sarò
vabbè vabbè ai ragazzi per oggi
concludiamo qua veramente raga io siamo
arrivati ad un punto solo continuano
perché già ai livelli prima andavano
oltre le nostre competenze questi
lasciamo perdere ragazzi spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto come se non ti
piace anche vari social comunità tutta
la descrizione sono sconsigliate noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo visto da ragazzo
[Musica]